like to add my welcome to that of being
coastline and Jamoris as they said it's
amazing task and it's amazing to see all
of you here in the class 400 400 alums
it's really fantastic I have the honor
of introducing our keynote speaker
castle a keynote speaker today is a
leader in the business community with
over 20 years of experience spanning 30
countries global sales business
development manufacturing and operations
in technologies companies gender
bachelor's degree in mechanical
engineering from lehigh university and
the mba from the university of dallas
she's held various executive positions
at Texas Instruments Raytheon Sun
Microsystems and lucent technologies
where she most recently served as VP
strategic alliances and new to business
development of global sales throughout
her career she did responsible for
building relationships of strategic
alliances partners on a global basis and
to leveraging these relationships to
drive new growth of both existing in new
markets and the successfully assisted
companies in worldwide strategies and
international business development she
joined Hitachi in May 2006 in this
currently vice president and general
manager it's my great pleasure to
introduce Elizabeth Liz King
good morning everyone and thank you dean
christine khosla and members of the
faculty for giving me the honor and
privilege of being with you today first
I would like to congratulate you a class
of 2009 on your fine achievement today
you now have a prestigious certification
of a high intellect and ability to need
to meet new challenges ahead of you as
many commencement speakers will say this
moment is more about the beginning of a
new journey than it is about the end of
one each of you now looks through the
doorway of the future a door that you
have prepared for and work diligently
for and now as you open that door each
of you will see very different things
why do you think that we can all look
through the same doorway and see so
differently when I look back to the day
that I was sitting in your seat it was
beyond my comprehension that someday I
would market and sell anti-radiation
missiles to our allies around the world
that I would travel throughout Europe
the Middle East and Asia negotiating
complex defense military contracts with
senior government officials move from
that career and to living through the
roller coaster ride of the internet
bubble boom and bust in the early 2000s
from selling servers to software to
telecommunication systems across 30
countries and now be responsible for a
systems division of one of the largest
Japanese corporations of the world there
is no way I could have planned this so
how did it happen well I did not do this
all by myself I developed relationships
with people who had faith in my ability
and guided me well so the first thing I
want you to look for is the value of
developing a high-quality network of
personal friends professional friends
and mentors it can comprise past work
colleagues Carnegie Mellon fellow
graduates and faculty here with you
today bosses sabor
its neighbors and family friends this is
a lifelong ever evolving process as your
network grows you will find it a
powerful and vital tool for problem
solving for innovation and an endless
source of new opportunities in times
both good and bad to date i've had the
privilege of working for five
corporations for each move that I made
my network played a pivotal role in
enabling that opportunity a friend of a
friend of my husband's open the door for
me at Sun Microsystems a former
colleague relation ships through
indirect paths introduced me to both
loosen and to hitachi of course I had to
compete to win each job but without my
network none of it would have been
possible a deep and active people
network will provide you a dazzling
array of opportunities and choices
another personal attribute that will
enhance your future success is an open
mind this can be tricky in a world that
pays for people with knowledge and
applied skill people who have the
answers the problem is the answer that
may have worked yesterday may not work
today and the questions always change in
fact the world is always about change it
is critical to be able to see change or
the need for change and also the ability
to initiate to adapt and to take
advantage of change I have found the
best way to cope with this chaotic world
that we live in to keep an open mind
conscious or unconscious constraints on
how we view ourselves our employer our
products our competitors everything
needs to be critically examined on a
real-time basis there's a great phrase
that comes to mind minds are like
parachutes they work better when they
are open let me give you a personal
example 14 years ago living in Dallas I
was summoned by my customer in South
Korea to begin negotiations on a large
government contract earlier than that
was planned I just returned from an
exhausting two-week business trip in
Australia so the last thing I wanted to
do is get on a plane so when a day I
dreaded to travel
on a plane I was not supposed to be on
in a seat that I wasn't supposed to
inhabit I met my future husband he's
sitting right there that meeting
completely by chance propelled me to a
new world called Silicon Valley and
launched a new career that only
continues to evolve and grow for me
every day by being open minded that day
my then adventurous life became an even
greater aventure personally and
professionally so next how do you
navigate through this dynamic high-tech
world years ago when the world was much
more linear the conventional wisdom was
to set specific goals and manage to them
a plus B always equals C well anyone
with a pulse rate over 50 knows that
life outcomes today re are more closely
modeled by quadratic equations and
pathways that look more like a strand of
DNA and not a straight line the modern
world is anything but linear so stay in
friendly relationship with this fact why
don't you replace a goal orientation
with a vector orientation go ahead and
set your goals but detach from the
outcomes focus on the vector the path
the challenges and opportunities of each
step along the way with an open mind and
a supportive network you will see more
possibilities for growth and new
directions and if you are fixated on a
single goal for every one goal you would
like to achieve there exist many others
of equal or greater value that you
cannot even imagine another aspect of
maximizing your future is how you go
about setting those goals on your path
especially in a job market today that is
increasingly competitive and filled with
qualified people so I say to you be bold
and take risks the entrepreneurial
stretch for that new experience that
will set you apart from others that will
give you a competitive edge now this is
easier said than done change and
risk-taking are not comfortable they
never are
there will be internal inertia others
will advise again you against or
seriously question your desires but if
you are not on the end of a skinny
branch wondering what am I doing here
you are not maximizing your learning you
are not expanding your abilities growth
always comes from climbing out on those
skinny branches so when you experience
those butterflies in your stomach or
sweaty palms know that you are doing the
right thing the final when one thing I
want to say about doing the right thing
the fact that you enrolled in this fine
University validates that you did step
out on that skinny branch final thought
I want to share with you about making
the most of your future is simple but
perhaps the most tactically challenging
you have got to be relevant to every
person in every situation every day you
need to be of value to others by helping
them achieve their goals and
accomplishing your own much as said
these days about branding and developing
your own personal brand this is what
others collectively think of you so it
is not something you control but you can
influence it and it always has relevance
as a major characteristic no matter what
your specific skill or job content we
are all measured somewhere along the
spectrum of winner to loser
thoroughbreds who also ran much of this
measurement is dependent on how relevant
you are to others and that what value
you can bring each and every day when
I'm at work I ask my teams and I also
ask myself are you driving value and if
so how are you driving it to our
division to our company and to our
stakeholders is that development project
underway still going to really move the
needle and achieve the expectations that
we set reflect on this question and
notice that it might make you
uncomfortable despite all the great
intentions the answer may have been once
yes but is it's still yes despite all
the great intentions now what are you
going to do has the market or the
competition or even your own companies
direction changed the game are your
skills what I record that are required
today going to be the same for tomorrow
it is critical to recognize the
situation in real time and then to take
action to reestablish your relevance so
in summary what you make of your future
first begins with how you see it and
that is best done with an open mind
secondly the riches of your experience
will be enhanced by enlisting the help
of others in a vibrant network of
mentors of teachers problem solvers and
sounding boards and you will nourish
them in return and give back thirdly to
make the most of opportunities in a
chaotic nonlinear world set goals but
develop a vector consciousness in
pursuing them life is full of surprises
the best way to deal with uncertainty is
to be in action and ride the vector
fourthly in your goal setting be
entrepreneurial whether it's a long-term
career goal or tomorrow's to-do list
reach for something new think out of the
box and take prudent risks do the skinny
branch work finally focus on being
relevant to others in every situation
every day demonstrate your value every
day the future is truly yours you're
smart you are accomplished now go step
through that doorway and make it happen
thank you and again congratulations
you